[Music]
so what is a smart goal well let's cover
the definition of a goal first a goal is
the desired result that you envision
plan and commit to achieving but most
people never reach their goals we live
in a microwave society we want our
dreams and we want them now without
putting in the work to get there but
goals are achieved in a slow cooker it
takes time which means small intentional
steps every day Chris Hogan's a
leadership in a retirement expert says a
dream without a plan is a wish yeah that
was weird
that's why New Year's resolutions rarely
work in January you can't find an empty
Stairmaster at the gym but by March it's
a ghost town where did all those people
go well we don't need an in-depth
Dateline investigation to figure out
what happened here they didn't set SMART
goals goals that are specific measurable
achievable relevant and time-sensitive
setting a resolution to lose weight
won't cut it but if you set a SMART goal
to drop 20 pounds by March 15 by going
to the gym three times a week and
cutting out milkshakes you'll be more
likely to succeed at Ramsey solutions we
recommend you set goals in seven areas
financial get out of debt save for
retirement and make a plan for your
money we made it easy with our free
budgeting tool every dollar spiritual
pick up a new devotional or get plugged
into a group at your church physical hit
the gym take the stairs and remember to
eat your veggies
except for beets those taste like dirt
intellectual go back and finish that
degree take an online course or just
read a good book family playing
one-on-one dates with your kids or your
spouse and make it a point to call mom
on Sundays which reminds me
mom I got your voicemail I'll call you
as soon as I'm done here
career be all-in at work make them glad
they hired you you hate your job maybe
it's time to polish up the LinkedIn send
out some resumes and call into the Ken
Coleman Show for help and lastly social
say yes when someone invites you out to
lunch
or for some of you say no more often my
friend Christie right founder of
business boutique says an honest no is
always better than a dishonest yes give
yourself permission to dream but then
set SMART goals to actually achieve them
one more thing this is on you if you're
waiting on something or someone to
change your life you could be waiting
awhile even longer than I've been
waiting for the secret of spacejam make
it happen LeBron
and now you know
[Music]
if you have a financial goal this year
we recommend Financial Peace University
it's a nine lesson class all about
personal finance taught by America's
most trusted financial guru Dave Ramsey
you can take the class with a local
group or work through it online
learn more at Dave Ramsey comm taught by
America's most trusted financial guru
and that guy sucks not you sir
you're great it was the truck it was the
truck that's a very nice man hello how
are you
good to see you thanks for being here